desde diciembre en francés un tema
recurrente en las conversaciones de
pasillo de las instituciones sanitarias
la vacuna contra la gripe la conocemos
hace tiempo la del coi es algo nuevo
tenemos derecho a hacernos preguntas yo
pienso que es algo positivo que hayan
encontrado esta vacuna y me pregunto que
tengo que hacer ahora yo creo que me voy
a vacunar por hay que vacunarse o no
contra el kobe 19 el personal sanitario
que estuvo en primera línea contra la
pandemia desde el inicio de la crisis
sanitaria vuelve a estarlo en esta
campaña de inmunización pero en francia
muchos continúan escépticos un 40 por
ciento según las encuestas en esta casa
de ancianos de sartre bin al noroeste de
parís es hora de pedir las dosis pero de
30 trabajadores sólo 4 han solicitado
formalmente ser vacunados la mayoría del
personal es escéptico y espera a ver los
resultados de la primera fase de la
vacunación porque creen que no tienen
suficiente perspectiva para decidir el
presidente del grupo propietario de
estas casas de reposo confía en el
efecto bola de nieve
mostrar que el presidente se va
y el hecho de que cada vez que vacunamos
en un hogar del grupo hay otros
trabajadores que se suman a la
vacunación influye en otros que se dicen
si mis colegas no han tenido efectos
secundarios porque debería tener loción
y reversión época como este hogar en
cambio ha vacunado el 85% de los abuelos
internos en su mayoría estaban a favor a
veces incluso en contra de la opinión de
sus familias
y yo desde que comenzaron a vacunar poco
a poco las personas más reacias
comenzaron también a vacunarse hace 15
días no era el caso
nuestro ejemplo sirvió para empujar a
los otros me parece magnífico que el
estado francés cuenta con el personal
sanitario para dar el ejemplo y
transmitir confianza a los más débiles
pero de manera inesperada la experiencia
está mostrando que los mejores
embajadores de la vacuna contra la cob
it son las personas más vulnerables